THANK YOU.
>> I BLESS YOU.
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
THE NEXT REVOLUTION.
I’M STEVE HILTON.
THIS IS THE HOME OF POSITIVE
POPULISM.
PRO- WORKER FAMILY AND PRO-
COMMUNITY AND PRO- AMERICA.
A HUGE WIN FOR BERNIE SANDERS
IN THE NEVADA CAUCUS.
EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED
THIS, CONGRATULATIONS VARNEY
AND DON’T LET THEM TAKE IT
AWAY FROM YOU.
I THINK HE’S ENJOYING THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE’LL GET INTO ALL THIS IN A
MOMENT ALONG WITH MIKE
BLOOMBERG’S HUMILIATION IN THE
DEBATE LAST WEEK.
WE HAVE A FRIGHTENING PREVIEW
OF THE LOONY LEFT CALIFORNIA
POLICIES THAT MAY BE COMING TO
YOU IN A MORE POSITIVE PREVIEW
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIP TO
INDIA WHERE HE ARRIVES IN A
FEW HOURS.
LIVE WITH ME AS KAYLEE, KEIRA,
SARAH AND HENRY.
IT WAS A BLOWOUT FOR VARNEY IN
THE NEVADA CAUCUSES AND HE’S
NOW THE CLEAR FRONT RUNNER.
IT’S TIME FOR A CLOSER LOOK AT
VARNEY AND IN PARTICULAR THE
SUPERFICIAL CLICHÉ TWEETED OUT
BY NEARLY EVERY PENDANT THAT
HE IS A POPULIST, THE
DEMOCRATS VERSION OF DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT IS COMPLETELY WRONG AND I
WILL SHOW YOU WHY.
FIRST I WANT TO SHOW SAY THIS
ABOUT HIM.
AYDEN MEYER HIM FOR PUSHING
HIM TO THE POSITION OF WHERE
HE HAS MADE THROUGH HIS
IDEAS.
MANY OF THE THINGS HE SAY ARE
WRITE ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
AND ON A PERSONAL NOTE I HAVE
A LOT OF RESPECT FOR NINA
TURNER, SHE’S A HUGE TALENT
WITH A BIG FUTURE, BUT, HERE
COME THE BUTT.
NO ONE SHOULD BUY DEPENDENT
EASY CONSENSUS THAT VARNEY IS
A POPULIST LIKE TRUMP.
HE IS NOT.
THERE ARE THE FOUR REASONS
WHY.
FIRST, TRUMP WASN’T OUTSIDER.
VARNEY IS ACTUALLY AN
INSIDER.
BEFORE ENTERING THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE, DONALD
TRUMP NEVER RAN FOR ANYTHING.
HE WAS NEVER IN POLITICS AND
APPROACHED IT LIKE A
PROBLEM-SOLVING BUSINESSMAN.
HE COMBINED TRADITIONAL
CONSERVATIVE IDEAS WITH NEW
MORE POPULIST ONE.
PRO-BUSINESS ON TAX AND
REGULATION BUT PRO- WORKER ON
TRADE AND IMMIGRATION.
PRO- AMERICA ON DEFENSE AND
PROFAMILY UNPAID LEAVE AND
CHILD TAX CREDIT.
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
AND PERHAPS IN THE LONG TERM
HIS MOST IMPORTANT SHIFT OF
ALL, UPENDING THE CONSENSUS ON
CHINA.
TRUMP’S ORIGINAL INNOVATIVE
POLICY MIX IS SOMETHING ONLY
AN OUTSIDER COULD’VE PUT
TOGETHER.
BY CONTRAST VARNEY HAS BEEN A
POLITICAL INSIDER ALL HIS
LIFE.
ALMOST FOUR DECADES HE’S
COLLECTED TAXPAYER-FUNDED
PAYCHEX AS A MAYOR,
CONGRESSMAN AND NOW SENATOR.
HE’S NOT EVEN INFECTIVE
INSIDER.
HE’S INTRODUCED 239 BILLS
WHILE IN THE SENATE.
GETHSEMANE BECAME LAW.
TWO.
MAYBE FOR ONCE HILLARY GOT IT
RIGHT WHEN SHE SAID NOBODY
LIKES AND NOBODY WANTS TO WORK
WITH AND MANY OF YOU GOT
NOTHING.
HERE’S THE SECOND REASON.
DONALD TRUMP’S POLICIES ARE
MAINSTREAM.
VARNEY’S ARE EXTREME.
THE POLICY AGENDA PRESIDENT
TRUMP RAN ON IN 2016 HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SINCE.
HE’S BASED ON MAINSTREAM
POSITIONS WITH MAJORITY
SUPPORT, WHETHER THAT STRONG
BORDERS, RENEGOTIATING TRADE
DEALS, CUTTING TAXES OR SCHOOL
CHOICE.
BUT BERNIE’S POSITIONS, THEY
ARE WILDLY OUT OF THE
MAINSTREAM.
THEY ARE EXTREME AND HAVE ONLY
MINORITY SUPPORT.
OPEN BORDERS, REJECTED BY OVER
75% OF AMERICANS.
ABOLISHING ICE REJECTED BY
OVER 50%.
PRISONERS VOTING REJECTED BY
NEARLY 70%.
ABOLISHING PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE, REJECTED BY A
MAJORITY, AND OF COURSE THE
MULTITRILLION DOLLAR GREEN NEW
DEAL, ACTUALLY THE CENTERPIECE
OF HIS PLAN FOR THE ECONOMY,
REJECTED BY A MASSIVE 67%.
YOU’RE NOT A POPULIST IF YOUR
POLICIES AREN’T POPULAR.
HERE’S THE THIRD BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN VARNEY AND
TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT STANDS UP TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
IN THE EARLY DAYS HE HAD
ESTABLISHMENT PEOPLE ALL
AROUND HIM, TRIED TO BLOCK HIM
ON EVERYTHING.
TRADE, CHINA, THE WALL,
IMMIGRATION, YOU NAME IT.
BUT NOW WE ARE SEEING THE
RESULTS.
THAT IS A HUGE CONTRAST WITH
VARNEY.
IN HIS LAST PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, HE WAS FIRMLY
AGAINST OPEN BORDERS.
>> SHOULD WE HAVE A COMPLETELY
OPEN BORDER SO THAT ANYBODY
CAN COME INTO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN WHICH I
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH, THERE
IS NO QUESTION IN MY MIND THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY LOWER WAGES
IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT HE REALIZED HE COULDN’T
GET ANYWHERE WITH THAT
POSITION IN THE NEW WOKE
ESTABLISHMENT SO NOW HE’S
COMPLETELY CAPED.
HE’S FOR DECRIMINALIZING
BORDER CROSSING, BREAKING UP
ICE, THE WHOLE CRAZY PACKAGE.
BUT HERE’S THE FOURTH THE MOST
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
THING THAT THEY MOST
INFURIATINGLY GET WRONG.
THEY CALL THEM BOTH POPULIST.
POPULISM MEANS TAKING POWER
OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE ELITE
ESTABLISHMENT AND PUTTING IT
IN THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHAT TRUMP IS DOING.
THE REGULATION TAKES POWER
FROM GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS
AND PUTS IT IN THE HANDS OF
EMPLOYERS AND BUSINESS OWNERS,
ESPECIALLY SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO WERE HURT MOST BY
OVERREGULATION.
THEY PUT MORE FINANCIAL POWER
IN THE HANDS OF WORKING
PEOPLE.
JUDGES ARE PULLING PEOPLE’S
RIGHTS IN THE CONSTITUTION AND
CURBING THE POWER OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE.
SCHOOL CHOICE GIVES POWER TO
PARENTS, PARENTAL LEAVE GIVES
POWER TO FAMILIES AND SO MANY
AREAS, TRUMP IS TRULY
DELIVERING THE POPULIST
PROMISE OF POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
VARNEY WANTS TO REDISTRIBUTE
POWER BUT HE WANTS TO TAKE
POWER FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ELITE AND GIVE IT TO A NEW
PUBLIC SECTOR ELITE, NEW ARMY
OF BUREAUCRATS AND BUSYBODIES
RUNNING AROUND TELLING YOU
WHAT TO DO ONCE BERNIE’S TOLD
THEM WHAT TO DO.
NATIONALIZED HEALTHCARE,
NATIONALIZED RENT CONTROL,
NATIONALIZED ENERGY.
WHEREVER YOU LOOK VARNEY WANTS
TO NATIONALIZE POWER.
POPULISM IS ALL ABOUT
DECENTRALIZING POWER.
VARNEY IS THE DIRECT
OPPOSITE.
HE IS FOR CENTRALIZING POWER.
HE IS NOT A POPULIST.
HE IS A SOCIALIST, AND BY THE
WAY, DON’T BELIEVE THE SPIN
THAT SOCIALISM IS NOTHING
UNUSUAL.
IT’S NORMAL IN PLACES LIKE THE
UK OR SWEDEN OR DENMARK.
THAT IS RUBBISH.
I KNOW THOSE COUNTRIES.
WHAT THEY HAVE IS NOT THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISM.
IT IS SOCIAL DEMOCRACY AND
IT’S TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
NOWHERE IN EUROPE IS IT
EXTREME AND BERNIE’S PLAN FOR
AMERICA.
EVEN IN THE UK WITH THE
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE, IT
DOESN’T BM PRIVATE INSURANCE.
SWEDEN HAD MASSIVE SCHOOL
CHOICE AND DENMARK HAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST LEVELS OF THE
GALATIAN IN THE WORLD.
VARNEY IS A WASHINGTON INSIDER
WITH EXTREME SOCIALIST
POSITION WHO PANDER TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT WHEN IT SUITS
HIS OWN POLITICAL PURPOSE.
I’LL GIVE THE LAST WORD.
TO A WELL-KNOWN DEMOCRAT WHO
DOESN’T THINK DEMOCRATS WILL
BUY WHAT THEY ARE SELLING BY
VARNEY.
>> THEY’RE NOT INTERESTED IN
SOCIALISM AND REVOLUTION AND
ALL THAT.
>> AND IN ANOTHER INTERVIEW HE
WENT A LITTLE FURTHER THAN
FOOLISHNESS.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE AREN’T INTO
ALL THIS DISTRACTING BELIEF
ABOUT OPEN BORDERS AND LETTING
THEM VOTE.
THEY WORKED THEIR WAY THROUGH
SCHOOL, PAID OFF STUDENT
LOANS, THEY DON’T WANT TO HEAR
THIS.
PEOPLE DON’T WANT THAT.
THEY DON’T WANT SOCIALISM,
THEY WANT POPULISM, POSITIVE
POPULISM AND FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
BUT THE PUNDITS KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK AND WHAT THEY’RE SAYING
ABOUT VARNEY.
PLEASE SEND THIS AROUND THEM